let's bring in senator tom cotton he's a
member of the senate armed services
committee uh the two big stories we're
going to talk about both of them with
you let's start on the vaccine mandates
you know when i always think about a
presidential
are unvaccinated addre hopefully be
persuaded to be vaccinated and i'm not
sure if attacking them
actually gets you further to that goal
senator
no dana it doesn't and this new federal
vaccine mandate is just a political
distraction it's probably unlawful and
it's almost certainly counterproductive
political distraction because joe biden
campaigned last year preposterously by
attacking donald trump for this vaccine
when it was unleashed in the world by
china but he said that he was going to
get it under control he thought the
economy was going to bounce back because
the vaccines the trump administration
created yet here he is after the
disastrous afghanistan withdrawal with
his poll numbers plummeting he's trying
to shift the focus away from those other
crises back to the pandemic when it's
really his fault for having campaigned
on this last year and attacked by or the
trump administration and even attacked
their vaccines as he and harris did that
we have surge in cases once again
it's probably unlocked the senator
doesn't regulate
public health
so yeah i mean osha regulates toxic
chemicals and and like unsafe
scaffolding they don't reckon they don't
regulate epidemics and finally dan as
you suggested it's ineffective i mean by
scolding and condescending to americans
dripping with scorn that somehow this is
their fault that they've been infected
with a virus they're not going to
persuade people to get more vaccines
look the vaccines the trump
administration created in record time
are very safe and effective i would
encourage everyone to talk to their
doctor about their own personal health
conditions and then consider getting it
but dictating it through unlawful means
in the kind of dripping scornful way
that joe biden did yesterday is not
going to help
okay senator i apologize for
interruption here we're balancing two
significant stories as you can clearly
see today
ron klain the chief of staff retweeted
something from stephanie rule from msnbc
said osha doing this vax mandate as
emergency workplace safety rule is the
ultimate workaround for the federal
government to require vaccinations so i
mean
maybe in a sense that's how they see it
as you refer to ocean your answer there
now i want to go to the taliban and i
want to take you back in time six seven
years uh to the release of beau bergdahl
knowing who was in charge of the taliban
government today we got two sound bites
i'll play them separately for you the
first one is from june of 2014. this is
anthony blinking saying
the trade for the five taliban members
for beau bergdahl was going to be okay
in the end this is what he said any
threat they would pose to the united
states and to americans has been
sufficiently mitigated now i want to
play a clip from you from march of 2015
the next year jen saki on fox reacting
to that similar comment
was it worth it absolutely we have a
commitment to our men and women serving
oversea or serving in our military
defending our national security every
day that we're going to do everything to
bring them home if we can and that's
what we did in this case
six years later senator how did those
comments play
well not very well bill as i said at the
time those five detainees at guantanamo
were not low-level goat herders they
were high-level commanders and we see
that now because they all hold
high-ranking positions in the taliban
government along with for instance the
minister of interior who's in charge of
security in afghanistan was designated
as a terrorist by the obama
administration and the emir of the
islamic new islamic emirate of
afghanistan he encouraged his son to
become a suicide bomber a few years ago
so no that doesn't seem like a very
moderate business-like taliban yet this
administration seems more concerned that
the taliban cabinet is full of men as
opposed to being concerned that it's
full of terrorists
senator cotton we appreciate your
thoughts this morning as we reflect on
this day before the 20th anniversary of
9 11.
it's just really remarkable that this is
where we are it was not sufficiently
mitigated as promised thank you